good morning John it's time for doing
another weave thing day today and today
we're going to be translating one of the
coolest URLs on the Internet
into a video with the web page at this
URL it was formed through a combination
of user submissions user curation and
algorithms to be 25 all-time top most
useful highest rated lifepro tips of
Reddit and I thought that I could make
it the smidge easier to learn those top
25 ways to make your life better
number one top tip write down all the
nice things that happen to you over the
year fold them up put them into a jar
and the New Year's dump them out and
remember all the nice times that we all
too often forget number two camping but
your headlamp is too weirdly bright but
not bright enough cuz it's a
unidirectional and not ambient drive
into a water bottle and turn it on yeah
what's nice right
that's pleasant white text with a black
outline can be read on any color the
alien blue app is an excellent way to
browse reddit on your phone tap with two
fingers for enough vote three fingers
for down vote I had a co-worker stealing
your pen take your blue or black
cartridge out of your blue or black pen
and put it into a pen with a froofy
color cuz nobody steals paint pens when
browsing for plane tickets use your
browsers incognito mode open travel
websites if you don't buy the first time
will raise the price if they see you
come back at second time because they
know that you're more likely to buy it
jerks having a hard time untying a knot
twist the thing that the knot is made
out of to compress it and then it will
be easier to push it through it's not
actually as useful as the pro tip makes
it sound other things that's all in the
comments if you bang on or bite a knot
that will help loosen it as well
if the twisting doesn't work oh LCD gaze
is lying around anymore but if you need
one you can make one out of a sheet of
paper a little bit of scotch tape for
extra security that's not a container
you need to fill with water but it's too
big to fit in the sink dustpan yeah
let's do a hole in my stupid dustpan so
I have used duct tape which is like
lifepro tip number one right PLC is an
amazing piece of software that lets you
watch pretty much any movie format ever
also it has a mixer inside if the
dialogue is too quiet and the action is
too loud you can mix it good eggs sink
bad eggs float add / zip to the end of
it image your album you get the whole
album downloaded a zip file so awesome
save your fingernails use a staple
remover to open
keyring we all know ctrl or command V
pastes but ctrl shift V pastes without
formatting till your water bottle
epicord away with water and throw it in
the freezer then whenever you want to
fill it up all the way you got ice cold
water to cut one of your old cables is
in danger of snapping you can use the
spring from an old ballpoint pen to
reinforce it you want to cool down your
beverage without watering it down you
can throw in some frozen grapes rather
walnut on damaged wood to cover up dings
and I don't know who cares so much about
their dinged furniture I don't have any
examples of that I walnuts eat them
their food make amazing ramen with this
extraordinarily detailed infographic
that's linked in the description put a
rubber band around your paint cancer you
have something white your paintbrush off
that's not the side of the cans gets all
messy then get more out of Google with
this other extraordinarily detailed
infographic that's linked in the
description for word spam text to 7:00
7:00 to 6:00 all carriers will then use
that information to track down the
spammers and finally if you find
yourself in an emergency do not say
somebody call 9-1-1 either call 9-1-1
yourself or tell a specific person to
call 911 and this has happened everyone
assumes someone has already done it
which is terrible thanks to all the
original posters make sure that you go
check those out because usually with
reddit post the comments are better than
the original post anyway check out the
live pro tip subreddit it's a great way
to spend time and also the nerdfighters
subreddit is a pretty cool way to spend
time John I'll see you on Tuesday
[Music]